there's this line from She-Hulk where
she's saying I deal with anger on a
daily basis when men tell me about my
area of expertise and when guys look at
me on the street you don't know anything
about anger as she points at Bruce
Banner someone that apparently the law
suggests his Hulk Persona is his abused
child battling with his real adult self
you're genuinely going to sit there and
tell the guy that was abused as a child
that the fact that men can't call you on
the street is somehow comparable the
fact that she compares herself to what
Bruce endured right but this is another
way that they're really driving home
that point that men are so clearly worse
than women in so many different ways
that it took Bruce I think something
like 15 years to come and really
integrate with his shadow and here she
is putting down a man that has been the
Hulk for so many years and dealt with it
for so many years and he has his
expertise and there's no room for her to
even consider that he might teach her
something irony you know completely lost